What's the Difference Between Brown Eggs and
White Eggs?
There are all sorts of rumours surrounding
brown eggs and white eggs.
Some people say that brown eggs are better
for you and contain more nutrients; some people
think brown eggs taste better; some think
that brown eggs are better for cooking things
like quiches, while white eggs are better
for baking cakes (or vice versa, depending
on who you talk to).
We here at Today I Found Out are all about
uncovering the truth amongst all of the myths,
and so here is the fascinating difference
between brown eggs and white eggs:
Brown eggs are brown.
White eggs are white.
Seriously, brown or white, they are the same
on the inside, with one minor caveat which
we’ll get to in a minute that has nothing
to do with whether the chicken is a brown
egg layer or white.
But besides that caveat, a brown egg or a
white egg will give you the same amount of
nutrition, they taste the same, and they are
equally delicious in quiches and cakes.
The two also have more or less the same shell
thickness.
The differences in shell thickness that you
may have observed likely has to do with the
age of the chicken- young chickens lay eggs
with shells that are typically harder than
older chickens’ eggs, but this is true for
both white and brown egg layers.
How the rumours started about brown eggs being
“better” is thought to be because they
are often more expensive at supermarkets.
If something costs more, it has to be better
quality or better for you, right?
Not in this case (and not in many others either-
increasing the price of something, sometimes
drastically, is an occasionally used marketing
trick to get people to think one product is
better than a comparable cheaper product.
Sometimes that’s true, but many times it’s
not.)
As for egg prices, brown eggs cost more in
part because the hens that lay them usually
eat more, which means the hens cost more to
keep per egg.
You see, white eggs are most often laid by
white or light coloured hens with white ear
lobes, while brown eggs are most often laid
by red-feathered or brown / dark-feathered
chickens with red ear lobes.
(This is not a universal truth, just a general
rule.
Further, the chicken’s ear lobes are really
the indicator here, not the feathers, but
there is a very strong correlation between
ear lobe colour and feather colour, so feather
colour can be a decent indicator too.
Ultimately, egg colour is determined by genetics,
but the ear-lobe / feather colour thing is
a good, though slightly flawed indicator.)
In the end, red-lobed chickens tend to be
larger than their white-lobed counterparts,
which is why they eat more.
The farmers need to get reimbursed for the
extra feed somehow, so they up the price of
the brown eggs.
This also explains why white eggs tend to
be more popular in supermarkets.
White-lobed chickens cost less for farmers
to keep, which leads to cheaper eggs, which
leads to grocers buying more white eggs to
put on the shelves to offer this product cheaper
to customers.
White eggs are simply more cost-effective.
There is also a commonly touted myth that
brown eggs taste better, and that’s why
they’re more expensive.
As noted, this white egg / brown egg taste
difference is a myth.
But the potential difference in taste from
one egg to another does lead us to our one
caveat, though it isn’t anything to do with
the colour of the egg—rather, it has to
do with the chicken’s diet.
Many chickens raised at home are brown-egg
layers, while most of the chickens raised
for commercial use are white-egg layers.
The different diets affect the taste of the
eggs and even the colour of the yolk, similar
to how diet can drastically affect the taste
of the meat of some animal.
However, if you were to take one of those
brown egg-laying chickens and raise it on
the same food as a white egg laying chicken,
their eggs would taste the same and be otherwise
indistinguishable aside from the colour of
the shell.
If their diets are the same, the yolks will
even be identical in colour.
Today, chickens raised for commercial purposes,
whether layers of white eggs or brown, are
all getting fed the same thing, with perhaps
just a slight variance from company to company.
If you’ve had some brown eggs from a neighbor
or a chicken of your own that’s fed a different
diet than commercially fed chickens eat, then
there may be a difference in taste.
It just doesn’t have anything to do with
the colour of the egg.
So, if brown egg-laying chickens are more
expensive to feed and to keep, why do farmers
keep them around?
The answer is that so many people buy into
the “brown eggs are better” myth that
brown eggs are still a viable business option.
As long as people keep buying the more expensive
eggs and are willing to pay marked up prices
beyond factoring in the extra feed, farmers
will keep raising chickens that lay them.
Of course, these days some of the most hotly
debated arguments aren’t over white vs.
brown eggs, but over the superior quality
of organic vs. not organic eggs, or free range
vs. cage eggs.
While differences in diet can affect the taste,
if you’re wondering about quality of the
egg or nutritional value, a study done by
D.R. Jones et al. through the Agricultural
Research Service and published in Poultry
Science in 2010 found that, ultimately, there
is very little difference in the quality of
eggs produced in these different ways.
The small differences they did find “varied
without one egg type consistently maintaining
the highest or lowest values.”
So, in the end, while there are small ways
the composition and taste of chicken eggs
can be influenced, the colour of the egg shell
isn’t one of them.